Congress will continue to argue over the
potential release of the now infamous
four page memo compiled by Devin Nunez
congressman David Cicilline is a
Democrat representing Rhode Island the
smallest state but one of the best he
joins us tonight congressman ex-criminal
my pleasure things so at the core of
this memo which I have not read there
probably a lot of stuff the memo but
here's what we know is in there
something that we know is true which is
that Obama officials approached a
federal judge and asked for a FISA
warrant to surveil Carter page who was
an advisor to the Trump campaign on the
grounds that he was a foreign agent
who's a spy for Putin's government do
you think Carter page was a spy for
Putin's government well I can tell you
I've read both the Nunez memo and the
Democratic memo so I can't talk about
the contents of it but what we do know
is it was a memo prepared by a partisan
by Devon Nunez who in fact was so
partisan in this investigation that he
was removed from leading it it's a
summary or port should be a summary of
classified documents that he's never
even read and so partisans are in
Congress no no Mike I just don't want
people to be confused this is not an
intelligence document this is a document
prepared by a partisan who has already
demonstrated his inability to be
objective here accused itself let me
finish and he purports to summarize a
set of documents he's never even raised
is why I didn't ask you a question
either about Devon Nunez or about the
documents I'm asking about publicly
available information that is of concern
to all Americans the Obama
administration made the case that Carter
page was a Russian agent and on the
basis of that case spied on the Trump
campaign so I'm asking you was that
legitimate do you think Carter page was
a fly again I cannot comment why because
I know but you haven't read the memo
I've read both men I can't comment but
you don't need to have read the memos no
no that no no but you cannot comment on
things which potentially are in under
New York Times story you can't come in
new you're just comment on the memo
calling a partisan I don't know what I'm
saying I'm talking about what that
memo does here's what we know we know
that the Obama administration argued
that Carter page was a Russian agent and
use that information to spy on the Trump
campaign is that okay is my question
what do you think of that we have in
place and again I cannot comment about
this particular what I just said what
I'm saying is we have certainly in the
public domain an ongoing investigation
about Russian interference in our
elections there is a process to conduct
that investigation which is underway
this is sadly another attempt to
undermine that investigation to create
this memo in this hole I'm sure there's
a lot of politics but that's an American
I don't my harder pain I know I don't
want anyone know but do you interfere
with American presidential okay but I'm
not trying to but my other concern as an
American is that the government might be
spying on people for political reasons
and we know that the Obama
administration spied this is I mean
dispute this if you want these am I
wrong agencies yes I take any allegation
about government surveillance very
serious I spent my career practicing
criminal defense work and it's a really
so no question did the Obama
administration I spy hole it is just let
me finish the question and then I really
want you to do your best just to answer
this question and I'll concede every
other point did the Obama administration
as News reports suggest authorize spying
on someone involved in the Trump
campaign I cannot answer that question
based on my I would be concerned at any
time that a process was not followed
created by the FISA Court and all the
standards that apply to that no one no
one's alleging that the federal judge
who approved that warrant was out of
line or the people who asked for it I
just want to know what you think of the
allegation that Carter Page was a
Russian spy cuz it seems insane because
now he's on MSNBC graduate from the
Naval Academy it's not like this guy is
disloyal that we know to his country
again we have lots of examples where the
federal government conducts
investigations both counterintelligence
and criminal investigations that's
an important part of what they do but
you nervous of a political keep this
wicked oh no no you haven't made our is
the Trump game because three years
should have eyes on the Kamla Harris
campaign because it doesn't make me
nervous because I have confidence in the
men and women the professionals at the
FBI who take their responsibilities
seriously who have a whole range of
responsibilities to me there's oversight
no - questions about the government
cannot say don't ask questions but what
we're in gate wants sadly what we're
seeing now is just an ongoing effort to
smear the FBI to attack not by you I'm
saying Republicans in Congress and the
problem is it's an effort to undermine
this investigation I think to set the
stage for the nomination maybe for the
firing Robert Olerud rose real questions
I'm a civil libertarian Democrats used
but why didn't oh they're pure put but
right but why is that why is it why is
it Tucker then when the Democrats sought
release of the democratic memorandum
which went point-by-point to answer
those questions every single Republican
on the committee voted against it's no I
think they should I think it should all
be released tomorrow I mean I'm on the
releasing side always congressman thank
you my pleasure great to be late